[Music]
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the King died that was
last night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just want to say quick thanks to my
cast and crew it's been a great sheet
and thanking UK anime
[Applause]
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry brings
fish comes on the king tide that was
last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
from far away I'm looking for warriors
this stranger others like him
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
Barry Allen Bruce Wayne
you said that like it explains why
there's a total stranger sitting in the
dark in my second favorite chair
he said he'll fight with us more or less
more more and more less probably more or
less he said no they said no look man I
don't know who you are but whoever
you're looking for
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team with special abilities you see I
believe enemies are coming I'm gonna
stop right there I'm in you are just
like that yeah I need friends right guys
hate this
[Applause]
I heard about you didn't think you at
real
I realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
[Music]
you
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea